welcome to this video playing our
tactical tactical I played him before
just just recently okay with III d phi
is playing a completely non theoretical
opening let's see input the d6 maybe
don't want to trade on just try to keep
stuff on the board here we get some
Kings Indian tribe of position where III
is not a very attractive move problem
okay maybe increase the pressure here
yeah this is this is a typical Kings
Indian type of position gets in before
and I couldn't really do anything
against that but it's not it's not fade
like and still hold the fort on the on
the queenside and try to get something
going on the King side yeah okf 595 I
already don't want us want to see so
maybe I can just take and player 5 it's
not an ideal setup but what can you do
the question is what to do with the g7
Bishop not a really good piece okay he's
some going for a quick c5 I guess okay
my idea was an IgA Bishop h6 bit slow at
them I need to try to get rid of this
piece yeah he wants to play civ 5 really
quickly yeah I really don't don't
believe in F for this is some this is
not what I want to do maybe maybe this
is the right way to go intending 93 and
at least getting some some stuff traded
a break with the pawn problem now after
c5 I have a form okay
thank you efore 94 that's not really
looking good it's simply simply a bad
position it opens up my position
terribly but I need active pieces some
active pieces my deaf 634 would be nice
if it would be possible it isn't
unfortunately maybe here get to g4 has
got 94 so coming but well okay what a
disaster
you know 94 is probably just good I have
no no discovery or anything oh that's a
very ambitious not bad probably but
still very ambitious ok take here take
on d5 ok he didn't plan that this is a
sir born out of necessity as d phi was
hanging and I'm is still a bad position
it's still a bad position ok whatever I
can I have no way to to get a decent
game anymore it's just they're just a
terrible position ok anyway to get some
sort of play 93 Bishop c4 or something
this chicken before it is really just a
check here there's nothing more
happening maybe Queen no 24 Saudi
playable yeah I came give this chicken
there any way to to get to get a good
play Queen rooks Europe here at least at
some a threat now you can just play
locally to for example some minimums of
some little tricks are there but it's
very very high more easy to to prevent
night here this chick nothing really
working probably need to do that there
is no no trick or anything Quincy 6e
just takes that's that's the real
problem here yeah can take d4 just win
very easily
what's a f5 I mean just check check
check group Brooke everyone mate look
everyone mate the only movement ahead
but it's efficient yeah you really let
me back into the game that's quite
remarkable the the check the problem is
that i'm winning and losing on time of
course yeah it's a broken record I know
but this is the problem with this tongue
control people don't need to win in case
of Europe being low on time they can
play any any any move and went on time
he simply didn't finish me off here but
but he went some time anyway in a
position which I was probably minus 20
or something yeah it was just it was
just far too bad i mean i was playing
this opening a bitter yeah the term a
bit too too relaxed here this this is
very good for white or any problem it
very difficult to get any sort of play
he has a c5 idea and all this yeah I
have no half no setup here that still
leads to a decent game I mean this is
not not possible to play
yeah well he just overlooked at d5 hangs
button it's a queen d 7 s in fact quite
good for black yeah this wasn't planned
as mentioned but ok I didn't I didn't
see that let's see form and no after the
six everything's nice for white again I
mean here I can I can I just have some
checks but there is no no real counter
play I mean he must avoid stuff like
that of course it's quite funny but it's
easy easy to do and here I'm just lost
jack totally but he didn't really does
not need to win again on position
because he will win on time anyway moves
like these seven or so just finished
black often be jolly and check he just
he overlooked this is rook f1 yeah okay
it's probably still in Los but the way
he played it with Brooke to g1 of course
black shouldn't lose anymore but okay I
don't have any increment so it's it's
pointless um yeah still the deserved
loss in a way because the opening play
was Scylla was far too far too bad here
okay thanks for watching